we have spent plenty of time on
spreadsheet so we're gonna have a big
break from that I thought we'd go from
you know laptops and Technology all the
way the other way and get some stuff
that you can hold with your hands okay
yeah old-school is exactly right so the
whole idea with the spreadsheets was
that I did mention to you in the general
course right you have to spend time on
technology on spreadsheets specifically
right but we run out of time there's
never enough time to spend in class
doing the kind of stuff that we did and
you'll kind of be expected to like we
found that out to you to do as homework
or that kind of thing but you know on
your own it's quite hard to do like you
saw how many struggles we had even with
people around to help you right so that
was the idea behind that this is what
we're about to do is much the same okay
it comes under something you're gonna do
next year which requires some time which
requires some outdoor stuff okay but
before we get to that we need to we need
to build all right so therefore the
heading I'd like you to make is area
yes yes we should
okay so you tend when you're ready I'll
just wait for your attention and then we
can begin you don't you don't know
you're not the only one in this
classroom in our class we have a bit of
a rule which is that if you are how do I
have my status if you if you act in a
way that causes trouble for other people
we ask you to apologize and to apologize
it probably there's a particular way to
apologize no wait a minute we don't just
accept sorry right yeah that's right so
because you're new because you need I'll
let this one pass and I won't give you
the whole treatment and also because you
weren't the only one but but after we
get through this I might go through the
steps you might might have tell me all
right so here's what we're doing
I've got a whole bunch of cardboard here
right and I'm gonna be I'm gonna using
them as props because you know that's
why not okay I've given you some
cardboard
I heard that you'll see next to someone
with a different color now he's what
you're gonna need to do you tend I'm
gonna do a series of shapes as I said I
forgot the glue sorry about that you
have to stick it in on a later occasion
I'm going to do about four kind of four
and a half shapes okay now all of mine
are huge because I'm up on the board but
you're gonna need to make your piece of
cardboard blast through the four shapes
so don't make your shapes as hot as mine
you might go stick them in anyhow okay
the reason why I see you next is someone
who has a different color is so that you
can use each other's colors and look a
bit nicer and you know actually some of
the things I'm about to do actually rely
on there being more than one color as
you'll see shortly
so first let's remember what you
what is area how would you define it
okay so now we're saying talk about
dimensions like up and down and back and
forth like that's linked okay and we
will get to that when we start to have a
look at the shape but I'm trying to look
about something think about something
mean okay so what was that like it like
a word for where I'll credit that
equally to both of you because you did
have it yet two terms so let's all get
that down area is the space the space
taken up by and I'm gonna push on that a
little further taken up by a 2d
two-dimensional shape space taken up by
a 2d shape I'm going to avoid the word
inside because as you'll see later on
not today but later lessons insights
kind of an ambiguous word so space taken
up by a 2d shape now where does it begin
what's the most basic shape the most
basic shape and we know very good it's
the square okay so get yourself up your
scissors right and try your best
maybe what your nose is draw a square
and then cut it out but um I'm always
wanting to say this here's one I
prepared earlier okay so there's a
square right now it is the simplest rate
so I've got a high key up and they're
gonna make you but it's a square right
it's a square so these are equal right
so I would I would put like a line there
I like that right so it's gonna Saint
quiet and link really all the sides
sides they're all the same right so
that's guess I can call this s as well
okay so this area of a square
is s Swift so then we move on right
that's the simplest kind of shape but go
a little further what's something with a
little more complexity to it ah the
rectangle actually comes next will come
to the Train what a second I wonder me
to think by the way of why this shape
actually does come before the Train
so here we go here's our rectangle okay
now this is coming to what amy was
mentioning the area of a rectangle is
equal to now it needs two labels all
right and there are a few different
labels that get used with a rectangle
the most common ones are L and beans you
know deceitful and so the area here if
you can imagine is like dividing this
rectangle up into a whole bunch of
squares right so if I divide it all a
lot you know how many would I have
across this way that'll be the breadth
and how many would I have up and down
this way that'd be the length okay
so then you multiply them together so
far sacred or just you don't need the
multiplication sign do okay okay